go to the clintons go to the clintons
you were talking about everything with
the clintons why do so many people when
it comes down to Clinton's get suicided
uh you know we hear that answer for that
but I mean I can give you my opinion
yeah that's what I want to hear why we
hear these stories and then you know I
want I want to ask you whether you feel
Trump has any kind of a involvement with
Epstein not in regards to business but
with women because I have my own Theory
there as well but let's start off with
the clintons first uh okay so the
Clinton stuff is really complicated and
even I like with the book you know I
sort of saved some of that stuff for
last and I it probably should be its own
book because this Mark Middleton guy
most of his meetings were with Mark
Middleton
um you have these visitor logs came out
right last December at 17 visits it's
much more than five with Mark Middleton
and then just a few months later Mark
Middleton dies in Little Rock Arkansas
uh he was allegedly found hanging by the
neck from a with an extension cord
around his neck and a shotgun wound to
the chest and it was labeled a suicide a
local orcas Arkansas said that no media
front taken at the scene photos videos
anything is allowed to be released to
the public huh what he was hanging
supposedly
this is again from the Daily Mail citing
local law enforcement that you know it's
it's very crazy
I mean listen if you can commit suicide
by hanging yourself and shooting
yourself with a shotgun in the chest
you're a magician is what you are I mean
you're you're in a league of Europe yeah
and so this is right after it comes out
that he's you know meeting the guy that
met with Epstein a bunch of the Clinton
white house but it's even crazier than
that because you once you start looking
into who Mark Middleton was at the White
House it gets crazy really fast I'll
give you an example George W bush comes
into office are you familiar with the
first time Bush invoked executive
privilege
uh among other things I think there were
three things in the particular document
that was you know that invocation but
one of those three was all documents
about Mark Middleton not going to
Congress which was investigating Mark
Middleton why did Bush step in to
protect a Aid to the Chief of Staff of
the White House for Clinton who's
normally you know he's not a big fish
right yeah what was it why is Bush
stepping in for that what's your thought
well uh if you look into why Mark
Middleton was Infamous at that time and
why he was being investigated it's
remembered really only by U.S
conservatives today and they refer to it
as China Gate
um which is kind of a largely forgotten
political Scandal it's insane once you
get into it I personally think China I
think China Gate's kind of a misnomer
you you do have China involved but
really it's the same it's some of the
families that backed Bill Clinton uh
when he was governor of Arkansas uh the
reality family Jackson Stevens these
types of figures uh when Bill Clinton
becomes president they have a lot of
interest in uh China stuff and and
mainly it looks sort of like a lot of
tech transfer stuff to China and so it
can serve us at that at the time said it
was basically the the clintons selling
out uh U.S national security on a major
scale to uh the Chinese government or
mainly uh to firms that were you know
state-backed and tied up with the the
Chinese military
um and uh Mark Middleton was one of the
guys at the center of this and Epstein's
meeting with him at the same time that
China Gates active and oddly enough in
the same period of time and I mean this
is why it's so crazy uh Jeffrey Epstein
on behalf of Leslie Wexner is involved
in moving an airline called Southern Air
transport from Miami Florida to Columbus
Ohio to run cargo for The Limited and um
sorry I got away from the microphone and
that's the airline that used to be air
America the CIA Airline and Southern Air
transport was involved in the Iran
Contra stuff moving stuff the Mena
Arkansas Barry seal the cocaine stuff
all of that was Southern Air transport
and then just a few years later it
becomes the airline of the limited and
it's not going from Miami to Latin
America anymore it's going from Columbus
Ohio involved with Epson Wexner it's
going to Hong Kong
and this is the guy at the same period
of time he's meeting with the China Gate
guy I mean there's a lot of really crazy
stuff here and honestly it would take
the whole podcast to unravel it all I've
tried to do my best in the book but
there's there's really a lot more there
and it's it's very crazy and the other
guy at the center of this was Commerce
Secretary Ron Brown who agreed to
cooperate with an investigation into a
lot of this stuff and then he ends up
dead in a plane crash that kills a bunch
of people in the Commerce Department
that are at the exact part of Commerce
ITA at the Commerce Department who were
that was basically the department most
targeted by this particular group for
China Gate is this the one where 34
people died and they said there was a
radar failure and then the next day the
radar failure guy was killed or he has
he had a yeah he was shot in the chest
and it was real to Suicide
it was in Croatia Ron Brown uh after he
agreed to investigate was was told he
needed to go on a you know urgent trade
mission to Croatia and that's when the
crash happens and I think actually
Maxine Waters at the time I requested
there be further investigation because
he was found with an odd wound in his
head that was consistent with a gunshot
wound and the x-rays disappeared and a
lot of crazy Maxine Waters wanted it to
be investigated yeah well actually like
when Gary Webb wrote a you know dark
Alliance and all this stuff she also
called for their doing investigation but
that doesn't mean it went anywhere you
know Maxine Waters congresswoman well I
think she was a bit different in the 90s
than she is now yeah no question let me
just bring this down to earth for a
second because obviously we can go the
whole Charlie Day yeah but the Clinton
stuff's really crazy yeah right yeah you
know all these theories and and the
stuff that we're hearing and we had a
whole conversation about distrust of the
media you know the the stories about
politics and clintons and the media and
the lies and the money and not trusting
what you're seeing not taking things at
face value
how should the average person I'm just a
normal American I'm just a normal
citizen paying my bills got my family
how should they process just the news in
your opinion you mean like mainstream
media yeah just you know living my life
I'm just hearing you know doing what I'm
doing um I think mainstream media has uh
evolved a lot over the past few decades
right I think uh you know I I've been
out of the uh this is my first time back
in the US in like eight years my parents
I was at their house a few days ago they
watched the evening news all the time
like ABC and when they're talking about
a government story they just cite the
government sources and that's all they
say they don't you know look to see if
it's true they don't do any sort of
Watchdog stuff they're just telling you
uh what the official story is about
really anything and you know to me
that's being more of a stenographer than
being a journalist I don't want to be a
normal person right now I want to be an
abnormal person and go back to Clinton
so let's go back to Clinton's okay so we
did Middleton we did Ron Brown who else
when you see the link to these guys
Esther you got a few of these guys that
you can I mean it's just it's so nuts I
mean I would encourage people to read
this part of the book because there's so
much detail it's so convoluted and
insane when you get into the the stuff
about this and even the Congressional
reports that were done about China Gate
I mean it's totally insane what happened
uh it's very like illegal and there was
a focus on the illegal campaign
donations but it was basically like pay
for play politics but it was pay for
play politics where these illegal
campaign donations were being uh
obtained from non-us citizens and it was
basically buying influence of the
Commerce Department that was seems to
have been signing off on basically Tech
transfers of sensitive like military and
other types of Technology uh to our
ostensible adversary and when it wasn't
supposed to be sent over there and also
stuff about China's trading status like
most favored nation trading status
because Clinton campaigned on playing
Hardball with the Chinese about out that
stuff and he totally reversed right and
a lot of this is because of this this
one family that backed his political
career going way back named the riyadis
that are actually Indonesian but they're
ethnic Chinese and they have a lot of
business interests and all of Southeast
Asia they're very big they're called the
Lipo group and um the Lipo group and and
Jackson Stevens these guys have a
relationship with BCCI that we talked
about earlier back in the 1980s and
actually tried to save the BCCI Hong
Kong Branch before its collapse and
that's when they went into business uh
with some of these Chinese
government-owned firms and that's where
China Gate really starts and it gets
really crazy from from there on out but
talking even not talking about China
Gate anymore you look at the first time
Epstein went to a Clinton fundraiser it
was supposed to be for the White House
historical Association nominally a
fundraiser so Hillary Clinton could
redecorate parts of the White House
um
I don't even I feel crazy talking about
it just because it's so insane but this
fundraiser Epstein was involved in he
was one of the donors to that you also
have one of the guys instrumental in
BCCI stuff like Clark Clifford uh who
was in the Carter Administration and
played a major role in bcci's entry into
the U.S financial system
um and then you have a guy named C
Gerald Goldsmith who tried to run for
mayor of Palm Beach once who has a bunch
of ties to Offshore Banking complex
organized crime I mean a lot of the guys
not everyone obviously but some of the
guys that attended this fundraiser are
Financial guys like that right and this
fundraiser ends up in Vince Foster's
suicide note
what does that mean are you familiar
with Vince Foster yeah of course he was
White House counsel
um and Clinton yeah and he died and uh
there's a lot of speculation about what
really happened there
because you know he supposedly shot
himself in the mouth but there's no
blood at the scene right
and uh the autopsy report said it was a
mouth to neck wound and then they
changed it you know on some pages it
says that on some pages it says like you
know it was a regular
gunshot wound and then the people that
were at the scene are advised about the
autopsy late and they show up and all
the part of the mouth and neck the
palate all this stuff is just taken out
of Vince Foster so they can't look at it
or yeah there's a lot of weird stuff
going on there I mean I know I know you
know the specifics about the the death
in in the book and why people
suspect something but it's pretty much a
matter of record that when police went
into Vince Foster's office after his
body was found there was nothing in his
briefcase and then somehow like 36 I
think hours later the White House claims
there was a suicide note that Vince
Foster left and it was apparently
Hillary Clinton's office that was
responsible for finding that suicide
note after this extensive delay and the
only mention of Hillary Clinton in that
suicide note is related to this White
House historical Association fundraiser
so if you like this clip and you want to
watch another one click right here and
if you want to watch the entire podcast
click right here
[Music]